[Music]  families people will force here stuck  here for a century  that's knowing silence it's the only  thing that hasn't been taken from you I  [Music]  need an emergency assistance the Wind  River Indian Reservation  I'm June banner FBI that's Cory Lambert  he's the one who found the body  didn't you people get the memo that it's  spring but welcome the way only  how far do you think someone could run  barefoot out here I knew that girl she's  a fire this is a homicide  you driving this Fed around they asked  me to do about what I'm doing what are  you doing  no hunter you think of doing  you think that multiple assailants  shouldn't we just maybe wait for some  backup  Disneyland the backup Jane this is a  land of you're on your own oh my god  most don't kill unlucky hear each other  weak ones you don't think I can't make  it out here you cannot believe that once  is not ever  now here you survived you surrender  [Music]